Así es pues Incluso en los pirineos
orientales ahí en la localidad de hostes
es donde se dieron las temperaturas más
altas para una para un mes de octubre
fueron
33.8 grados
centígrados lo que marcó el termómetro
allí en ese lugar pero digamos que en
promedio Pues en todo el país los las
temperaturas estuvieron en unos 17
grados que sea tanto de día como de
noche y esto está unos tres a cuatro
grados por encima de lo normal y de esto
pues sale que este mes de octubre pues
entregamos en los libros digamos de los
Records desde que se hace la medición de
temperatura aquí en Francia esto es
desde
1945 ahora pues todos los expertos todos
los científicos Lo que dicen es que
ahora cada uno se está dando cuenta que
los efectos del cambio climático pues se
están viviendo de manera bastante
importante y ya de manera muy clara
según con esto que ocurrió durante todo
este mes de octubre pero también con
todas las temperaturas muy altas que se
vivieron a lo largo del pasado verano